[Music]
hey little liars welcome to our
second-to-last episode of the Rosewood
rundown I'm Liana gelareh I'm Katy
Krause and today we have two very
special guests
Sasa Peterson and Marlene King applause
it was very exciting here okay guys
that's why we had to shift stuff our
dynamic as to where we're filming but
thank you ladies so much for joining us
we really appreciate it or we get into
our bombshell that when I remind you
guys to send in your series your
questions we promise we are going to get
to as many of them as possible right
guys yes Marlene had maybe a similar if
you will come out accidentally
accidentally I don't know you gotta
magusis spoilers for us to either delay
let's talk about last night's episode
let's dive into our three biggest
bombshells of the night oh my goodness I
cannot believe that that was our
penultimate episode of pre-law yes of
all that would sizzle as well that was
written by Joe Doherty he's one of our
go-to awesome writers he also directed
the episode and we as a writers room we
really set out to make that feel like a
finale like if this wasn't the series
ending coming up that would be like a
big bold finale last night I was going
to say what did you want to set up or
convey in that episode I really in an
odd way a sense of closure we got a lot
of answers and the PLL has got to sort
of take a breath so we set up next
week's episode really with a fresh start
almost yeah I love it
let's talk about Emily's dream with
everything that we saw in the Pretty
Little Liars five years forward jump
yeah and I understand did you guys
reshoot that scene yet well we kind of
have to the record contender yeah
weren't sure where to send it in
I really enjoyed that with the whole it
was hot yeah hi Carolyn and that was fun
to film we always have it was eventually
it was when we shot that was our first
it was the 5a finale and it was the
first time we get to see the looks of
the new girls and so go and then going
back a year and a half later and
matching those look entity and
everything was
kudos to hair and makeup yeah they do
such amusing tone you talk about the
decision Marv to make that a dream
sequence well I'll be super honest when
we first shot it we didn't know who it
was
if we wanted to it was a last-minute
decision to add that scene to the script
because we just want to give fans a
sense of what that flash-forward was
going to look like and for a year and a
half we have been pondering like who was
later was it and but we knew we're going
to kill Archer so it could be him and
then then we just thought you know what
let's just really have fun with it in a
Pretty Little Liars thriller sort of way
and make it a nightmare also really cool
that wall was film that's just that is
that enabled yeah that's how he was able
to punch through the wall and like yeah
it was cool who did that
one of our stunt guys oh yeah yeah I
think he would have loved to have done
that yes it was really cool way to do
that I got asked about the chalkboard
there was a name on there Alison De
Laurentiis feels that is not hinting at
anything to come I mean it is but we
love to drop Easter eggs and and hence
so you know maybe tune in next week for
sure to find out okay our second biggest
bombshell of the episode we found out
who killed Cece Charlotte Charles yes
yeah talk about the decision to make
that amount mm well Mona is such a
beloved character on this show and and
first we knew that we wanted Mona to
ultimately end up spiraling into this
game it's sort of one of the most fun
things about her she's the most loyal
friend to Hanna but she has poor
judgment also and she can't not get
caught up in the in these games right
and so for her the game continued and
this idea that Charlotte was going to
continue the game really put Hannah's
life life at risk and she didn't intend
it wasn't something she intended to do
he really did just want to scare her
what about the game going to Edison's
house how did that happen will we get
answers to that in the sleeping gas and
hey does it like an amazingly smart
person hyper intelligent hyper
intelligent and and we always say that a
whether it was a big a or now ad uber a
ad has unlimited resources and unlimited
brainpower that's how we've always sort
of thought about aids business it was
interesting that we did see how CC got
the mark on the back of her neck that
eventually was the cause of her death
does that mean that we can put the
suitcase rumors to rest that it wasn't
Melissa's suitcase yes okay yes all
right
will that being angle so I feel like
they kind of ran over Emily to get that
piece will we get answers or will that
come back up in the finale but III think
that you know a ad and and the people
who've been helping ad you know we're
also chasing a few threads and a few
clues themselves there were there have
been other people looking for ad or the
identity of FA D and that some of that
you'll find out in the finale okay our
next bombshell of course Mary Drake's
big confession and the fact that she
left the into a Lee I am thunder her
lawyers the sort of blueberries I love
Andrea Heine Larry where I love my
dearest friends we double-date with her
and her husband all the time she did not
yeah we do but she's such an amazing
actually not Sasha IVA Sasha yeah oh
I've never you're going to yeah we
should be a triple Damon oh yeah yeah
yeah she's she's and also think of it
that Mary is also a hyper intelligent
person I mean we have sort of discovered
that she's got all those books she
speaks many different languages she's
such a sodden character just meant a lot
I'm sure small - you know cuz pens are
so smart but I figure out all the liars
this season especially Hannah we've seen
kind of becoming very smart women does
we're not always for time anyway
Arya going in with the hacking skills I
know I was that
and by osmosis and by just like watching
Caleb I think and all yeah hi you know
brilliance Lucy loved that yeah yeah you
guys she wanted to be bad for so long
and it took us a while to really figure
out how we could make you know Aria you
see her dark side talk about her kind of
talking to the dead body in her trunk
because people were like is that enhance
of like multiple personality disorder
yeah are evil personality
okay I thought it was just like common
she was regulating herself right kind of
calming yourself down okay so now were
you can with him Tasha I wanted to talk
to you because I talked to Trey and
earlier this year and she said that you
and Andrea sat down and really discussed
a dealer at his family tree oh my yeah
we wrote it down I remember we like took
a script and like turn it over and like
wrote the entire thanks Carolyn how does
that tenants okay Mary Drake well that's
my like we rest like we defected in with
the you as well cover yeah we have a
crazy insane what about Jason when is
Jason coming back believe me I'm not
gonna be in the finale as there are
couple actors that we really tried to
get but they were booked on other shows
and legally they can't come back to us
so he's one of those but but somebody we
tried all seem to get get back who is in
the finale and on another show is
Melissa Torrey DeVitto
so we're really excited about that how
old Melissa has returned affect the
Hastings and a DiLaurentis is dynamic
you'll just have to wait which leads us
into our pretty little flashback of the
week because it definitely has to do
with this twisted DiLaurentis Hastings
family okay so let's take a look back so
I'm dying to get you guys to sauces now
from season 3 you guys oh my going way
back going okay here take a look the
last time I saw someone in the state
clinging to a secret this hard it was
Alison
he weeks later she was dead Alison where
were you I thought you were asleep in
Spencer's room I had to go out what for
what what happened to your mouth it's
bleeding I'm SS scratch myself on a tree
branch on my way over to the house can I
go upstairs please
why did you have to go to your house at
3 in the morning mrs. Hastings please I
can't talk about this dun-dun-duh bloody
Ally's lip we're gonna dream I wasn't a
tree but I think it was during that
episode in Ali's life she was really
sort of taunting and torturing the girls
about these older people she was hanging
out with this sort of bad crowd and and
I would say as a writers room we never
said specifically in our minds who it
was it was that group of people if she
was she was trying to make the PLL
jealous you hang out older people
probably probably Charlotte I wouldn't
presume by that time how much can
college kids you know the same group of
kids that threw that poor girl down the
stairs and broke her leg so I thought it
lives in that world what about the nad
club talking about the older kids it's
so crazy or forgot about that
is there anything in the finale that you
can tell us about the nad Club will we
learn more not back we sort of wait
don't but what's that I thought with the
season 5 hey Bali they grew up and it
was thought it was a group of people who
were peeping toms they were spying on
people for kicks and then as the tapes
got out and and their secrets got out
that got people killed by Garrett and
people like that yeah Oh Garrett Karen
you guys are killer
yes killed so many people which is kind
of crazy you still keep talking about
the fact like remember wood Aria kills
someone yes your honor
yeah
that was an accident yes we laughs all
right back to public of course like the
smallest one yeah she just go in today
knock her off her feet
yeah no houses never kill someone
wait than the cause of I think all of
them but she's never actually killed
someone Wow marriage is not I'm gonna
kill Hannah chels Archer Archer
that's right Hannah killed Archer Aria
killed Sasha no Sean I don't think
expressly held anyone that we know of
that we know of
hmm Shana Aria killed Shana oh yeah I
like Emily killed me every day
and Mona killed Charlotte who comes
Wilden again Oh Ashley helped it go but
I don't know that was know it
well done was Ashley Marin I have to go
oh well no no no no you should yeah he
got shot
they turned her right yes oh I gotta go
back a tot and she's left him this is so
fun Charlotte Charlotte shot Wilden
Charlotte I dare you I am over with a
car yeah right and then Charlotte shot
him in the woods I'm pretty sure and
then broadcast two in front of the
church and left him there to frame the
girls yeah very habit see he'll go
connect with job there's a little time
and your favorite I know it was pretty
little liars if we just had to be like
who killed my way house that we've been
all right with it
yeah all right yes well we've been
following the show but this is really
fun for me to actually sit with you guys
and and do that no it's better than sir
diagrams oh yeah we've already been
asking so many questions Katie I think
it is time for our special finale
edition of the Rosewood fast five yeah
so we have been asking Sasha you
answered these last week we've been
asking so many of the PLL stars a same
series of questions but Mar we altered
this one a little bit so that users play
too so they didn't get off
yes yes an ally edition so first one how
many weddings will we win if I tell you
that it ruins the first hours of finale
for you I'm not gonna tell you okay well
I know each couple has the most shocking
seeing in finale oh come on you're by
girl my ax
I now I maybe I should tell her to say
without giving something you don't have
to give away what happens just which
couple has a shocking something happened
to the shocking is innocent yeah we'll
take a romantic way or the identity of
the baby's father way well we can say
that we finally yeah yeah you wanna talk
about why go I was allowed - who you
know is for you but there are snipers
coming from the free hands building
we're gonna buy where you're coming now
wrong is going to come up like a
thousand yeah when I talked to you last
week
you said something about oh there's one
of them side asked is there an
engagement or a baby name and people
right into that and said wait does she
mean only one baby name is and there's
two babies can you yeah I don't know
okay thank you yeah in their little this
should be like a sure to have especially
a like yeah yeah yeah can we trip it
should might well it is call the resin
read down so we're gonna try okay and
I'm number three who has changed the
most after the one year time jump in the
finale took Tobey
oh I wasn't expecting I was not
expecting that I was expecting out yeah
okay I turbulence what was the most
difficult scene to shoot you don't have
to describe the scene or I know for me
but you know first me um it's a it's a
tie between the goodbye scene for
for how the fans will see it okay which
we didn't shoot as our last beam that
was really hard potentially because we
never lose our ruin it was our lab be
able to handle our so exactly and then
the actual last scene that we shot
we were so emotional because the way we
were filming it a character was on
camera and the rest of us weren't and so
when were Elsa we were in the scene so
when we called cut it like we knew like
oh that's it we're done and there were
so many people around the monitors so
there was probably what I would say a
hundred people including us and like we
all had our PLL jackets on and it was
like that's it it's it was the strangest
feeling and the whole day was a real
victory ELISA however and our line
producer had made these the high school
yearbooks for us oh and I'll be the
girls gave us all our high school
jackass and what which were so cool and
into the end of the day everybody was
signing yearbooks it was like the last
day of school but I would say that for
me the scene that was brutal but I think
more brutal for you guys the very last
name because I decide to say action cut
and but he was so hard there's a scene
that was the gabbai scene where the the
PLL's are saying goodbye to one of their
characters that felt like such a final
goodbye like that was I I couldn't talk
and I have had my leave - oh my I had
the hardest line of the scene it was
like it's some song - oh really
I begin to understand a word or sale
you're just you're crying so hard that
real crane jump rupture so it was hard
it was right I mean we were all dreading
that scene for the whole episode because
we knew it would be so so brutal which
is why we didn't make it the very last
scene we shot because we would have been
there all day
yes well and I miss leads perfectly into
our last question which was how would
you describe the very last scene of the
series in one word the very last scene
has a very yes so the fans will see on
video what exists you remember what that
is
did you sell
it's that full circle it's a full circle
moment yes yes yes yes a bonus full
circle moment yeah but I think they
always leave that like tag after yeah
it's sort of that although this show
ends the world content it was one of my
favorites
I was like I was going to say what was
your reaction when you read the final
scene um I'm so glad that you put it in
there because it didn't like necessarily
shock me but it was epic and I was like
that is amazing
we are some song we learned all in a way
it was like that is so pol and was that
your own goal when you were writing it
Mar to make it a full circle moment yeah
I just to know that the mythology of
this town will always go on it's not
going to end with with the end of
preload layers yeah we are starting to
get so many fan questions there's so
many things you guys the let's start
okay Courtney says now if Mona killed
Charlotte your real name is Gordon I
mean I mentor yeah boy you know are we
short Ali's twin in the book and we're
all you Sara Shepard fans out there
Courtney said is Mona killed Charlotte
who pushed her off the bell tower and
post your body with the purple roses
mark okay yeah so Mona did do that
alright I had both of those those were
written by Jeff Doherty so I was a go in
my mind make sure my little okay missus
but yes Jessica says anyone noticed how
scared Mona looked last night when Caleb
sat in front of her or how pompous he
was taking that pie from her
my bed is plenty mom's by the way he
loves doing that in at the table read he
was like oh yeah I needed a action at
the cavalry like these days all right hi
Isabel character aria and Ezra fan yeah
area hi um well and also speaking of
that scene I loved it a little bit of
humor that you put in right before Caleb
and Spencer go down the hole she look
easy to the ladies room that's I think
that's what this show does but we have
so much fun with it's life and death
snakes but at the same time you can
laugh and get laid
to everyone Caleb's always been that way
they've always like taken gigas want to
humor yeah now we have asked both of you
about this separately but the fans are
clamoring for it so I'm going to put you
on the spot
what are the chances that we could get
an MSN spin-off for pretty little liars
well I mean everything is possible and
anything is possible people think that
your new series the perfectionist could
tie in somehow with a Pretty Little
Liars spin-off can you speak to that
yeah whoo so it could be in the same
kind of universe to be in the same
universe or feel like a similar universe
mm-hmm would any of the characters like
ally in that inside the parity or it
could be okay I would love to be honest
about everything through early I like
doing interviews with Marvel you're like
you're going to just twinkle in your eye
like we're here here comes the game we
get very excited be like a foot so we're
like wow I'm hoping in the next couple
weeks we can talk about more about the I
saw Sarah last week she's out here we
had dinner and we talked a lot about the
book and just about things she's doing
and things I'm doing and we love working
together so hopefully we can get to you
know do much more commanding whatever
sort and it's been so great because you
guys have had such an amazing creative
dynamic together to really take this
amazing book world that she started and
not only like bring it to life
especially in that first season but then
to build even more on that while still
having her blessing it's been so cool to
see over these past seven seasons she's
lovely and I think we all set out I
think everybody everybody read the books
either before the father or while we
were making the pilot so and and my goal
was just to to write these characters as
she wrote them in her book and be true
to the characters then we could go play
in our world and I think you guys and
everybody else did such a great job of
owning those characters and staying true
that for this whole time yeah and I love
how passionate she is about her show to
she's always so excited she came to the
set I think when we were filming the
last episode yeah well yeah yeah well
your sign which was so cool to see
umm so cute but it really was a cool
experience because she was so into it
yeah and she was so happy with I think
what you've done and I think she told
her story where she I don't know if it's
her first baby her second baby she went
into labor and she was at the hospital
she forgot to DVR everywhere so she
spent her mom home that's expected I was
like I don't want to miss the birth and
yeah like moms go home and set the DVR
prefer you know liar before we get into
the rest of our ad series because
there's so many good ones coming in for
the fans this is really fitting Mariah
says Marlene what has been your favorite
scene over the past seven seasons Oh
so that's really really hard but I mean
there's not an episode of hearts I feel
like that probably the scene we talked
about that's a goodbye scene is really
fun there's a scene after that that I
think is really fun
and I go back to the pilot a lot I think
finding Ali's body for me is a moment
that brought all the girls together
you're in the body bag but still very
much that was in your body but it's that
I seek out our goodbye episode I think
the pilot and then the I love the
episode where we've revealed that Toby
was on the a-team because I was so
shocked yeah all I was so shocked I
think that was still like one of my
biggest that went and I love all the
dollhouse stuff and then them so where
where you are locked in Radley with
Charlotte also was like yeah I really
thought it was it like you're just
you're in the one where we find out your
story the season four finale so
generally I love that one that was a
real turning point for your character
and brings your characters relationship
with the girls that was a beautiful ESCA
I feel like Ali's arc over these seven
seasons your character has been the most
chin away change
yeah and you were so sassy at first yeah
yeah yeah nice very good yeah big heart
and you're not as into the whole gaming
jac event see it was fun to be every
kind of Alison she really transformed
and no idea what I feel like they also
written by Joe the page
Allisyn scene yeah Paige really forces
Allison to get in touch with who she is
like self a transformative moment Eric
tur yeah and we finally insulted Ellison
finally resulted you know she finally
realized what she shouldn't hide from
herself anymore like which makes sense
that it was delayed because she doesn't
get to go to high school she didn't have
those growing up years
mm-hmm she was on the run for most of it
we play the sneak peek of the finale at
Zed and then we want to talk a little
bit about that and it takes my fan
behind for the best quality measure I
can look at through it easier for the
two-hour finale next oh my gosh it's
okay Chloe your engine take a look game
over it only one rule you don't look
back no more secret what is going on
I can't bury Ezra ad is revealed the
two-hour series finale I never would
have guessed it with you oh okay my
first question it looks like Mary Drake
is stabbing Spencer but we've seen them
have such compassionate and like loving
moments recently there's a lot going on
in that you were saving a lot more than
expect that were there any versions
before that promo that you were like no
because this hansteen can't be I've
always would take out certain frame oh
my god yes certains it but I think the
network has gotten so great at knowing
what what they can and can't reveal and
knowing what spoilers as opposed to what
just makes you excited never they're
pretty good at reading out those fellows
is there something then that happened
that makes Mary Drake well there's a
one-year time jump so a lot happen in a
year that sort of resets the show from
where we left it last night okay
are we meant to believe that that is
Spencer because there's rumors out there
that she has a twin and that is when our
yeah no Gary and I talked argue about
that about Oh Spencer okay the gun Ren
is there murders
yeah tell you that ok ok ok what about
something that I was like Oh
Jodi like this one my theory is that
instead of Spencer's twin theory it's
actually Melissa and a Spencer mask and
Wren is Melissa's helper Wow Jodi
hangeul theory yeah oh so there there
there is at least one mask in the finale
maybe two okay
are they a spoiler very realistic
looking back it is very realistic
looking all right we've tricked a lot of
people yeah I would have I'm a twig and
blue and hybrid laughing long will that
way Wilden match well yeah well that was
a fun senior that was such a fun season
yeah - oh yeah way and up yeah Jordan
said I'm convinced Ezra is a D who else
would be so interested in keeping aria
out of trouble and let's not forget he
had an entire layer when he was writing
his book there he had a good lair yeah
very good organized lair and Emma says
toby is probably not a d because
remember when he was chasing Emily in
the school and want to talk to her about
and he probably wanted to warn her about
Jenna Ramona oh my gosh you guys are
such good serious bad like watch the
show's over and over at home our again I
will talk I mean everybody knows I love
Toby so the chances of him being a B
would be slim right if someone were to
be so ambitious mark and we watch like
you all have to agree watch the whole
series before the finale is there a
certain episode in particular maybe one
that's early on in your life maybe pay
attention to this one I think it's
really all it's all of the these last 10
episodes we've talked a lot of Eastern
intentionally and to them because we
want a chance to have a really good
chance to to figure this out and be back
yeah you literally if you watch the last
time you like oh my gosh that makes so
much more sense there's it's fun it's
really fun you're going to love it are
you how are you I know that you've seen
that someone has guessed it correctly
online does that make you happy or do
you wish that you would still stumped
them
at first I freaked out and then I see
somebody else in Syria that isn't right
and I realized if you know out there in
the universe other way that I'm like
cool yeah when Brendan Robinson was here
he told us that you can go all the way
back and that there will be flashbacks
after the reveal can you kind of talk
about that montage and what that
flashback will be how far back will we
go
yeah well you don't it's really it's
really you go over the ridge expecting
it is all over the place but I feel like
there's I want to make sure that fans
understand it like this ad well
everybody is in ER woven yeah but but as
one story ends and other began so with
with the the reveal of Mona's then
became the Charlotte story and then with
the reveal of Charlotte becomes this ad
so this ad is separate in terms of
playing the game from those other always
nothing Atlanta game notice though going
back to like season one or two correct
correct
okay if we still somebody has a serious
IRS says I think aria is ad and has a
split personality disorder and doesn't
know what she did comes easy
yeah a lot of people are asking about
the promo and Azaria saying I can't
marry Ezra or I can't bury addre marry
marry marry that one we know okay yeah
there you're at - yeah no marry him I'll
be on the longing game yeah Rick we
won't do ginger says I think ad is page
nothing is worse than a love scorned you
know I don't know I love foreign boy
could be nasty - yeah true well hear
that well page be in the finale
I'm not going to fit okay okay any other
major returns that you can talk about
maybe some parents that we haven't seen
or siblings that we haven't seen in a
while I think we see some of the moms
are back okay right the ones that are
still alive
okay yeah does that mean Holly Marie
Combs is back yeah yeah yeah we haven't
asked her forever Katie should we ask it
now we have been yeah we're going to ask
you this involve season of the Rosewood
resident mom get out of the basement
wait till next week yeah well it's not
shale okay it's discuss it's discussed
maybe not completely in the way you want
but it is discussed it was my favorite
question I have that same question since
it happened I was like so what hell yeah
I do that what answer other buyers from
who is a B are you most excited to
answer for the fans both of you guys so
for me it's the why why is ad ad and how
did ad become ad okay
hmm if it's a question it's more so I
think I was amazed about how it happened
and how it was accomplished and that was
so fun but it really is the the Wyatts
it just it doesn't baffle you because
you want you you find out why and how
and you get to understand it a little
bit more but it's just so twisted that
it's really intriguing and I never it is
because I've never known how you guys
choose this when I read I think it's
done I like how are they going to move
on from this and it's just a whole other
surprise and it really does live up to
and you know maybe you guys can clarify
it a little bit because Mona said or not
Mona
Janelle sort of in diffusion L said when
she was here that further reveal it's a
little bit of everything at once like
we're finding out as the girls are
finding out it's not so much a reveal
can you guys explain a little bit of how
that happens I get how everything
unfolds yeah well sometimes it's also
the viewers will know before the girls
do which is always fun it's a little bit
there's not unlike sort of some of our
other finales that you the reveal this
is why we wanted to be two hours long
because we didn't want to leave fans
with a lot of questions so the reveal is
very important but then the
understanding of it is equally as
important so that's why it's two hours
so both the fans and the players can all
process it all at the same time well
speaking of that Sasha take us back to
the time when you were processing who ad
was Mar would you tell her like what was
just calm review Jedi
she didn't yeah
I was I was sneaky about it I was asking
all the right questions to the right
person uh Western is are we asking them
to I mean I don't know I don't know
anymore than you so I found out like
little bits and pieces and I was trying
to piece it together and so the person
who is ad asked me not to tell anyone
because that person didn't want to
affect certain scenes in certain ways
but I was like I never said anything
like please and I did end up signing out
before other people before most yeah as
people which I was proud of but I think
that's really the only thing I've ever
found or look at ya know before anyone
else for the most part everyone's been
on the same thing a lot of people found
out at the table read because we didn't
give the scripts out ahead of time and
as we got that ticket out into the world
but to be fair I didn't know how it was
going to happen I knew who when you
found out how what kind of went through
your mind like oh yeah yeah I hope
that's the shocking review on the cover
of Entertainment Weekly right really
it really really was so that's really
proud of it how did you tell this person
who was going to be ad that they were
going to be ad was that a separate
nomination a good one yes that was a
separate conversation that I had just
with that person fairly early on when
when the decision was made that that
would be ad because it affected a lot of
that person's I feel welcome we can put
a pin in that because spoiler alert
Marlene King is gonna be joining us next
week after the finale and we can fully
after all of the questions which I'm so
excited about oh yeah as you get into
this final two-hour episode what do you
think that true fans out there need when
they're going to watch it what should be
at their PLL viewing cupcakes yes I'm
coming to eat and hi yeah hi okay
tissues for sure was the what board
shorts sale if you're a page inherited
yes which now a lot of people are the
greater show which Italians that are in
fine I think friends if I would I would
try I met a woman recently she's thirty
now and she she should watched every
finale with her friends and now they're
going to watch the final finale all
together if you can watch it you know
watch it live with your friends but we
can all be there together yeah well you
guys all be watching it yeah yeah there
yeah amazing we'll be watching it yeah
probably leftover together we're gonna
be like having you back for next week
we're also guard be speaking with ad I
know I was like in a couple years it's
like where were you when you get back
thank you whoo I love that I'm just
going to be that iconic and memorable
that you will remember I think so that's
hope thank you ladies so much for
joining us we really appreciate it and
thank you to all you fans who've been
judging each event our our air is so
many amazing ones we have our very last
episode of the Rosewood runs down next
week at noon so stay tuned thank you
ladies again and we'll talk to you next
time bye
you
[Music]